foreign
listening to the show over the past
month or so you know that we have
returned frequently to a discussion
about the situation that young men face
in our culture and in particular as it
relates to marriage and you know uh not
only if you've been listening to this
past week but if you listen really at
any point that I'm a major advocate of
marriage that I especially encourage
young men and women to embrace marriage
and family life but there's been a
significant cultural shift away from
marriage in recent years with increasing
number of young people men and women
giving up on the institution altogether
and for men this shift has become its
own movement with its own name men go
their own way is what it's called and
the um the logic behind the movement is
that our culture is hopelessly corrupted
and the system is hopelessly rigged
against men and so that they're left
with no choice but to give up on the
system give up on Marriage give up on
the family and strike out on their own
focusing instead on their own
independence and sovereignty
as I've argued I understand the logic
I sympathize with those who are isolated
and lonely and feel that this is the
only path available to them but I don't
think that this that surrender is the
right response a man cannot give up on
what he was made to do and to be
to truly Go Your Own Way alone and
isolated is to give up on your duty your
legacy your ancestors your bloodline
your civilization your happiness
uh the movie Into The Wild tells the
story of a man Christopher McCandless
who went his own way to the extreme you
know burned a social security card left
his family hiked into the Alaskan
wilderness
and he died there alone and as he was
dying he wrote in the margins of a book
The Words happiness is only real when
shared this is one of the most essential
truths of human nature most of us are
meant to share our happiness with with
others
um and for most of us that's going to be
with a spouse and children
all that said
there are systemic problems with the way
that we approach and govern marriages in
our country and it is important that we
deal with and address those problems
which we which we usually don't
uh this is one of the central points
that a great many men have made to me as
they've given feedback on the topics
we've discussed on the show in recent
weeks I've read many messages like this
one just choosing this one random says
Dear Matt absolutely agree with your
message about the importance of marriage
I agree that men should become fathers
and care for their families I even
generally agree with your take on Andrew
Tate but you talk about these things
while never addressing this these
systemic issues you push for marriage
but pretend that no no fault divorce
doesn't exist your message will fall on
deaf ears as long as you refuse to
acknowledge
the whole picture
now for the record it's definitely not
even close to true that I never talk
about divorce or no-fault divorce in
fact I've been talking about it for as
long as I've had a national platform to
talk about these things at all
but if I'm being teed up to talk about
it again I'm happy to oblige which is
why the cancer leave for our daily
cancellation today is no fault divorce
now for those who aren't familiar with
the concept no fault divorce laws first
adopted by California of course and then
by every other state in some version
allow couples to break up their marriage
without any specific cause or reason
they don't need to prove that anybody
was at fault they simply tell the court
that they don't want to be married and
that's it
now in some states no fault divorce is
the only choice and at fault divorce
isn't an available option in these
states and the rest of the states no
fault is an option
that can be chosen
among other options but but here's
perhaps the most important detail
in most situations
it only takes one spouse to file for no
fault divorce this means that one spouse
can break the marriage contract without
citing any reason except irreconcilable
differences even if the other spouse
doesn't consent
and this is where the gender disparity
comes into play the vast majority of
divorces are initiated by women Studies
have also shown that women are more
likely to get divorced after getting
promoted at work
achieving greater financial success
that's what the this you know the the as
their as their financial situation
improves the likelihood of divorce
becomes even even more significant
meanwhile women are far more likely to
make it to make it out well in the
divorce receiving alimony other forms of
quote-unquote spousal support
now in theory gender is not supposed to
factor into who gets alimony or how much
they receive but in reality it almost
always does even the New York Times has
acknowledged this an article last year
remarking on how rare it is for women to
be forced to financially support their
ex-husbands reports this quote according
to a 2019 study of census data by the
urban Institute a non-profit research
group half of the United States
households are headed by women on
average while National statistics on
alimony aren't tracked Michael Mossberg
a new york-based lawyer and the former
chairman of the American Bar
association's family law section said
that despite an increase in stay-at-home
husbands far more women than men seek
and receive spousal support
so women are more and more becoming the
Breadwinners in their families and yet
the family court system doesn't seem to
have noticed that alimony payments are
still doled out like it's you know 1953.
what this means is that a woman this is
what can happen a woman can marry a man
leave him for any reason she wants even
after cheating on him
and still take half the assets and be
awarded with an allowance from her
ex-husband in perpetuity
it's not only outrageously unjust but it
also purposefully in disincentivizes
marital Fidelity while incentivizing
disloyalty and infidelity and divorce
there are many reforms that should be
enacted to stop the bleeding here the
alimony system for one thing has to be
drastically changed most alimony laws
were created under the assumption that
most women would be Housewives and they
would be stay-at-home moms and most
divorces would be initiated by men who
are the sole Breadwinners in the family
and in a case like that where a man
chooses to leave a wife who was staying
at home to raise the kids and take care
of the house
um and and he decides that he wants to
leave it makes sense that he should have
to pay she structured her entire life
around the assumption that he would
provide for her financially so that he
so that he could you know so that she
can care for the children and he can go
to work if the man decides to go shack
up with his secretary or whatever
he should still have to provide the
support that he promised
but this doesn't describe
all or even most divorces in modern
America given that again most divorces
are initiated by women
and also most women have careers
there's no reason why a woman with a job
who decides to leave her husband and
break the marriage vows
should then be rewarded with a monthly
stipend from the man that she wants
nothing to do with
I think a fair system would require the
person who destroys the marriage to pay
regardless of the gender and it can it
be difficult to decide who's at fault
for destroying the marriage yeah it's
difficult but that's that's
what needs to happen these are these are
this is why these courts exist to make
these determinations
and if the divorce really is a mutual
decision which I mean almost never
really is but if that's what they're
claiming then neither should expect an
allowance from the other if they both
have mutually decided this
I think the reform to no fault divorce
is far simpler it should be reformed by
simply ceasing to exist
marriage is much more than a contract
it's a covenant
but to the extent that it is also a
contract it's hard to think of any other
situation in which a contract can be
broken for no reason by either party
without the consent of the other and
entirely without cause
you know um it's hard to think of any
other contract that would work that way
but by treating marriage this way we
have downgraded the marital contract to
something less binding than like the
agreement you have with your cell phone
carrier we've made it into something
cheap and worthless
and that's how it's therefore treated
when you make divorce easy
and for at least one party concerned
profitable you get more of it in fact
shockingly when you make divorce easier
and and more profitable for one sex at
the expense of the other you get a
greater number of the members of that
sex initiating divorces
you don't need a crystal ball to predict
an outcome like this
people respond to incentive incentives
if you incentivize disloyal selfish
behavior you get more of it
however if you make divorce difficult
and potentially costly for everybody
involved not for one spouse but both
then you've given couples an incentive
to find another solution for their
supposedly irreconcilable differences
and you've sent the message on a
cultural level that the marital vow is
Meaningful and important and not
something that can be just discarded on
a whim
now no fault divorce Advocates will
argue that the alternative
divorce without the no fault option can
tend to be traumatic and it could get
really ugly
but there's no way around that and we
shouldn't look for one
like divorce is an ugly thing no matter
what
a promise was made a vow was made now
it's being broken
that's an ugly thing there's there's no
way to make this ugly thing not ugly
besides no fault divorce doesn't
mitigate the trauma or ugliness of
divorce instead too often it simply
shifts the trauma so that one party is
made to carry most of its burden
and that is the problem
and for that reason and so many others
no fault divorce is or should be
[Music]
[Applause]